I want to be is
healthy as possible eliminate as much
health problems as possible you know and
and try to be a hundred
I think 100 is a good a good solid age
man if you can make it to 100 because I
see people at uh at the gym this one
dude drinks he's like he's like 74. and
he's in there every time we get in the
gym
every time we go to the gym he's already
in there working out eight nine in the
morning and he's he's in there until
after I leave but he only goes in the
mornings he and I was we were talking to
him in a taller short he's about a
little about my height okay wow uh he
and he's 74 in shape and he's he said uh
he drinks one cup one cup of breast milk
every day he said he has 20 he has 20
something kids
and his kids have
kids
and then the mothers or even the
daughters or his daughters I think he
had the kids just to continue that break
keep getting a couple so he never runs
out of breast milk he said one cup
somebody somebody's having a baby and
somebody get a cup wow
I wonder does it have to be drank out of
like uh does it come from his own family
then I'm guessing he'll do that ask him
that he said yeah
one cup I wonder if I could handle it I
wonder if it would I don't know how he'd
if I'd have a reflect you know I mean I
think you just got to do it like just I
mean you know you're you know like ever
clear mix it with some uh ginger ale set
up set it out in the sun for about two
days right yeah maybe dog I don't know
if I could ever have any breast milk man
this girl Tommy laryn she has a friend
who has breasts who does breast milk out
of her breasts at parties and [__] oh no
but I don't like I don't like all of
that bro I think breast milk is
if I you know I wouldn't drink it out of
season what's the season for it I don't
know what what I don't even know if I
could do it like that is it like a you
know like they have that thing at
Starbucks that comes out what is it the
right like the like the uh the pumpkin
spice yeah calzone yeah like maybe in
the winter time I could do it you know
there's no calzone do a [__] lime
kiwi [__] licorice
croissant right it's a just a shot
just a little just a little yeah you'd
have to have it with something I'm
saying if I think if you were
something's wrong with you or something
yeah or have something before it I don't
think you go and just have breast milk I
don't know I don't think I would maybe
like melt some like vanilla bean Blue
Bell ice cream and you got a shot of
that boom take that back then you go
breast milk and then you go melted uh
vanilla bean uh Blue Bell again
yeah I think yeah you'd have to manage
it well because I don't know if you
could tell your neighbors and [__] about
it I just I don't want to be doing I
don't like to do things in secret dude
what if we are in the wrong we buying
all this other Goose milk and all of
this and animal milk and we're supposed
to be still having breast milk bro
it'll be a lot of saggy titties around
here but [__] boy imagine people beating
down their mama's door just to get a sip
at night to be safe for the morning she
probably eventually have to call the
cops
on you but that'd be crazy my son's over
here trying to suck on my tits again
I'm sick of his little ass bro
or I he ain't even my real son she might
tell him damn he over here trying to
suck on my tits
well the police come and say
the police
what'd they say they come up
maybe like
police yeah
you know what time it is come on open up
if he don't get it
[Music]
everyone wants it everybody wants that
[__] electric on mamas
damn boy
that dose percent oh
damn boy I [__] dip my dick in it bro
that should have probably because
imagine all the thing mother's milk
could do man I can't believe we forgot
what it does I don't know the science
science behind it I mean I know like
babies get and it's like that's all they
need you right right apparently yeah
imagine if we kept having it
but that's the thing mothers get kind of
greedy they put that they stop it after
a couple of months or whatever body
shuts it down says uh ah it's out of
season yeah yeah
wait till August baby
let's see at Starbucks
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one